[Musik]
Sie wissen haben wir gestern entschieden
dass Deutschland der Ukraine Waffen zur
Verteidigung des Landes liefern wird
auf Putins Aggressionen konnte es keine
andere Antwort geben wenn unsere
Welt ist dann muss auch unsere Politik
eine andere sein wir werden Russland
isolieren
wirtschaftlich finanziell und politisch
deutliche Worte heute im Bundestag der
eine Zeitenwende in der deutschen
Politik bedeuten herzlich willkommen
noch heute wieder zu einem zdf-spezial
über die einschneidende
Regierungserklärung ihre Folgen auch für
Deutschland berichten wir später
ausführlich doch zunächst schauen wir in
die Ukraine wo der Krieg weitergeht ein
Überblick über die lage von Cornelia
Donat
Kiews Innenstadt soll sich bislang gegen
russische truppenverteidigen können in
rakev aber sehen die 1,4 Millionen
Einwohner von ihren Fenstern aus die
russische Armee ist bis ins Zentrum der
Stadt im Nordosten der Ukraine
vorgedrungen
Raketen stecken in den Straßen der
Wohngebiete Bilder vom ukrainischen
Innenministerium veröffentlicht sollen
den morgen zeigen nach den heftigen
Straßenkämpfen der Nacht aber gefallen
sei hakiv nicht versichert der
Gouverneur auf telegram die Stadt sei
vollständig unter Kontrolle der Ukraine
verlassene Panzer Ruinen der Russen
sollen dies belegen ob es stimmt nicht
nachprüfbar
mindestens 13 Leben hat die letzte Nacht
hier gekostet über 100 sind verletzt wen
es nicht ganz so schwer getroffen hat
schützt sich mir den anderen im Keller
des Krankenhauses vor weiteren Angriffen
all die Menschen hier hatten nur eine
kleine Operation so wie ich
wir können hier runter die anderen aber
nicht
in der Nacht trafen russische Geschosse
auch eine Gaspipeline vor den Toren der
Stadt die Explosionen weit zu sehen und
zu hören
und die Kämpfe halten an Schüsse und
Sirenen lassen die Menschen rennen nur
weg von der Straße
bei diesem Einschlag soll ein Mensch
gestorben sein drei wurden verletzt
direkt vor einem Blutspendezentrum die
Mitarbeiter verlegen die Einrichtung
kurze Hand in den Keller
Angriffe auch in der Umgebung von hakif
gut 100 Kilometer entfernt nach Angaben
von ukrainischen Rettungskräften sollen
hier mindestens vier Menschen getötet
worden sein
im Separatisten Gebiet von donjet quo
Zerstörung und krieg schon lange Alltag
sind auch heute wieder Trümmer
Verzweiflung Leid
bombenteile seien auf das Haus seines
Nachbarn gefallen so dieser Mann nur
anderthalb Meter von seinem Zaun
entfernt
alle zitterten ich bin rausgerannt und
wusste nicht was geschieht weil es noch
dunkel war
eine Offensive der russischen Armee
erwarten Sie auch in saporizia die Stadt
liegt für das russische
militärstrategisch günstig am Fluss von
hier aus so wird befürchtet könnten bald
die nächsten Attacken kommen ukrainische
Militärkonvois haben sich bereits auf
den Weg gemacht um die Stadt zu
verteidigen
30 Kilometer südlich von Kiew stand
schon gestern unter Beschuss auch letzte
Nacht haben wieder Raketen die Stadt
getroffen diesmal auch einen öltürminal
ein Feuer Inferno die Bürgermeisterin
spricht sich und ihren Einwohnern Mut zu
der Feind will alles zerstören aber er
wird nichts erreichen den ganzen Tag
lagen wir und lag unser Flughafen unter
Raketenbeschuss und nun geht es weiter
aber alles wird gut auch wenn es nicht
leicht wird hier oder in Kiew mit Gottes
Hilfe werden wir das durchstehen
später folgte Entwarnung die Feuerwehr
schaffte es das Feuer unter Kontrolle zu
bringen auch verletzte gab es scheinbar
nicht
und darüber wollen wir auch heute wieder
mit dem ehemaligen Nato-General Egon RAM
sprechen guten Abend
s besonders unter Beschuss sind wohl
harkeefe im Osten und die Hauptstadt
Kiew wie sehen Sie die militärische Lage
im Moment
also nach der Berichterstattung die Sie
gerade gezeigt haben
würde ich das so formulieren dass die
Ukraine offensichtlich weiter sehr
nachhaltig verteidigen und dass der
Angriff der Husten zwar Raumgewinne hat
aber nach wie vor nicht in der
erwarteten Stärke bzw dem erwarteten
Umfang von daher stockt der Angriff und
muss abwarten in den nächsten Tagen wie
die Sache sich weiterentwickelt ja es
gibt Bilder von Bürgern die
Molotow-Cocktails basteln oder
Straßenbilder abbauen kann das bei der
Abwehr von solch einer massiven
Truppenaufmarsch helfen
also ich denke das ist nicht der
kriegsentscheidende Faktor wenn
Straßenschilder umgehängt werden oder
abgebaut werden aber es kann
offensichtlich mit dazu beitragen dass
bei den kartenmäßig schlecht
ausgestattet im russischen Gruppen die
ein oder andere Verzögerung aus auftritt
und das Molotow-Cocktails bauen sehe ich
mehr als ein Zeichen der Ukrainer die
offensichtlichen großer Breite bereit
sind sich gegen die russische
Streitkräfte zu stellen und das scheint
ein Faktor zu sein der von der
russischen Seite unterschätzt worden ist
von dem was sie mitbekommen reagieren
denn russischen Soldaten
also ich bin etwas überrascht gewesen
über Berichterstattung bereits gestern
und auch heute das offensichtlich
russische Soldaten nicht wissen dass sie
in der Ukraine sind und dort einen Krieg
führen und das ist das was mich
eigentlich sehr sehr stutzig macht der
Informationsweg innerhalb der russischen
Streitkräfte scheint möglicherweise
absichtlich sehr mangelhaft zu sein und
ich vermute dass das auch für die
russische Bevölkerung in der Breite gilt
und das nur wenige Teile der russischen
Bevölkerung tatsächlich wissen dass
Russland einen Krieg gegen das Bruder
Volk in der Ukraine
das ist ja kaum vorstellbar oder das
Soldaten gar nicht wissen was sie da tun
ja zumindest sage ich mal nach unseren
informationskriterien die wir haben das
einfach die tierisch Grundsatz der
lautete informierte Soldat ist besser
dieser Grundsatz scheint bei den
russischen Streitkräften nicht so sehr
weit verbreitet zu sein und das macht
die Sache vielleicht problematisch wenn
die russischen Soldaten insgesamt in der
Breite über den Krieg gegen die Ukraine
informiert wären dann wüsste man
möglicherweise nicht wie sich dann
weiter verhalten würden und ihre
Prognose für die nächsten Tage
also die Kämpfe werden weitergehen ich
warte immer noch darauf dass die
russische Seite gemeinsam mit der
belarus-seite die zweite Staffel
einführt in die Gefechte um die
Raumgewinne nicht zu erreichen man
bisher nicht kriegt aber ich bin auch
sehr überrascht darüber dass Putin ja
heute angekündigt hat dass die
strategischen Raketentruppen in
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt werden das
ist dann eigentlich auch schon sage ich
mal mit Blick auf die Kampfhandlung in
der Ukraine irgendwo ein Zeichen dafür
dass es bei der russischen Führung den
Eindruck hinterlässt dass es nicht so
weitergeht wie man das ursprünglich
geplant hat vielen Dank
ja es gibt seit heute Mittag Meldungen
über angebliche Friedensgespräche
Delegation aus Russland und der Ukraine
sollen sich an der belarussischen Grenze
Treffen für in Moskau was wissen sie
dazu
also diese Verhandlungen die sollen in
den nächsten Stunden starten die
russische Delegation die hatte aus
Belarus heute den Ukrainern ein
Ultimatum gestellt sie sollten sich bis
15 Uhr an den Verhandlungstisch begeben
ansonsten würde jedes weitere
Blutvergießen auf ihre Kosten also auf
die ukrainischen Kosten gehen
Präsident selensky hatte in den letzten
Tagen ja immer wieder gesagt dass er zu
Gesprächen mit Russland bereit sei quasi
überall aber eben nicht in Belarus und
er hatte gute Gründe dafür Belarus
abzulernen abzulehnen denn von dort aus
sind russische Truppen in die Ukraine
eingefallen und von dort aus wurden auch
russische Raketen auf die Ukraine
abgeschossen jetzt hat selenski also
eingelenkt und Verhandler ins
Grenzgebiet zu Belarus nach Belarus
geschickt die große Frage ist jetzt
worüber wird da überhaupt geredet ein
Mitglied der russischen Delegation das
hat heute gesagt man sei eigentlich
ziemlich kompromisslos was die eigene
Position angeht das würde dann bedeuten
dass Moskau darauf besteht dass die
Ukraine
entmilitarisiert wird und dass die
Regierung ausgetauscht wird das hatte
der Kreml ja in seiner sagen wir mal
sehr eigenen Wortwahl den letzten Tagen
immer wieder gefordert und silensky der
sagt er wird als Ziel ausgeben die
territoriale Integrität der Ukraine
wieder herzustellen wir sehen also dass
die Verhandlungspositionen denkbar weit
auseinander liegen ja wie ist denn
überhaupt gerade der Rückhalt für den
Kriegskurs von Vladimir Putin in der
Bevölkerung Wächter der Widerstand
also zumindest sind heute auch wieder
Menschen in Russland auf die Straße
gegangen in verschiedenen Städten und
das obwohl es auch direkt wieder zu
massiven Festnahmen kam derzeit hören
wir von 2100 Festnahmen im ganzen Land
es erfordert also wirklich ganz
besonderen Mut hier in Russland gegen
Putins Kurs zu demonstrieren und für
jeden der auf die Straße geht da gibt es
eben auch einige die den Kriegskurs
ablehnen aber dass sich nicht trauen
offen zu sagen wir wissen dass es viele
vor allem junge Russen gibt die sich um
die Zukunft diesem Land betrogen sehen
viele Menschen die Angst haben was die
Sanktionen für Ihre persönliche
finanzielle Lage bedeuten für die
Wirtschaftslage in Russland viele bangen
um ihre Jobs es ist schon eine bedrückte
Stimmung unterteilen der Gesellschaft
aber ob diese Menschen sich irgendwann
ein Herz fassen werden und ihre Meinung
auch offenkundtun und ob das dann
wiederum reicht um Druck auf Präsident
Putin auszuüben vielleicht seinen Weg zu
ändern das hört man alles abwarten
müssen ja der russische Präsident hat
die Atom Lehrkräfte des Landes im
Kampfbereitschaft versetzt was heißt das
denn praktisch
das bedeutet dass also zu diesem zu
diesem zu diesen Atomkraft
Entschuldigung noch mal von vorne sie
sind abschreckungswaffen gehören die
Atomwaffen aber da gehören eben auch zum
Beispiel
hyperschallraketen dazu ganz neuartige
Waffensysteme und
die sagen wir mal die Befehlskette ist
von diesem Moment an wo die in
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt werden ist
sie relativ kurz Präsident Putin hat
also eine weitere Eskalationsstufe
gezündet das muss man so sagen und er
hat das ja begründet damit dass aus
NATO-Ländern aggressive Worte gegen
Russland gerichtet sein worden sind und
da muss man also sagen dass diese
Begründung dass jetzt also wieder sagt
Russland sei ein vom Besten bedrohtes
Land und müsse sich verteidigen dass
diese Begründung ja auch dafür
hergehalten hat um in die Ukraine
einzumarschieren jetzt also ist es die
Begründung dafür weiter zu eskalieren
zumindest rhetorisch vielen Dank für
nach Moskau
ja und dann schalten wir auch weiter zu
unserer Korrespondentin Claudia Bates in
Washington wie ist denn dort die
Reaktion auf die Alarmbereitschaft der
Atomwaffen durch Wladimir Putin
es gibt noch kein Statement des Weißen
Hauses oder von Präsident beiden
persönlich seine Sprecherin jensaki
äußerte sich heute morgen in einem
Fernsehinterview und sie sagte das folgt
eigentlich einem alten Muster Präsident
Putin würde eine Bedrohung selber
konstruieren um dann die darauffolgende
Aggression damit zu rechtfertigen man
werde dem entgegentreten und man wisse
sich zu verteidigen außerdem hat sich
noch geäußert die die Botschafterin bei
den Vereinten Nationen der USA Linda
Thomas Greenfield sie sagte dass Putin
mit dieser Bereitschaft der
atomstreitkräfte den Konflikt auf
inakzeptable Weise eskaliere
interessante Aussagen gibt es noch von
Analysten das hat sich zum Beispiel der
frühere Verteidigungsminister und CIA
Direktor Gates geäußert der sagte man
keine Putin ja eigentlich als
meisterhaften Strategen und er habe sich
diesmal komplett verkalkuliert Putin
habe sich verändert er habe sich
gigantisch verkalkuliert indem er auf
die Zerrissenheit der NATO gesetzt hätte
das sei aber so nicht eingetreten die
NATO sei geeint und Putin sei jetzt
völlig isoliert und entgleist wir warten
natürlich auf ein Statement von
Präsident beiden rechnen heute auch noch
damit sicher wird er noch mal versichern
dass die NATO keine Bedrohung für
Russland darstellt und dann müssen wir
eben sehen ob auch eher die
Alarmbereitschaft hier erhöht vielen
Dank für die Einschätzung Claudia Betz
in Washington
ja und heute gab es auch ein
Krisentreffen der 27 EU Innenminister in
Brüssel in einer Sondersitzung ging es
um Hilfe für ukrainische Flüchtlinge und
ihre Verteilung innerhalb der
Europäischen Union
und in Brüssel begrüße ich jetzt die
Innenministerin Nancy fazer guten Abend
guten Abend Frau Piper hoffe wir erleben
dramatisches Szenen von Familien Kindern
die die Ukraine verlassen wie wird
Europa in dieser Situation helfen es
sind in der Tat furchtbare Bilder und
eine furchtbare Situation ich bin sehr
froh dass wir heute unter den 27
Mitgliedstaaten Einigkeit darüber hatten
dass wir jetzt helfen müssen es ist uns
heute gelungen ein europäischen
Schulterschluss für eine unbürokratische
Aufnahme von den geflüchteten zu
erreichen wir werden jetzt die
Kommission bitten einen Antrag zu
stellen damit unbürokratisch aufgenommen
werden kann innerhalb der EU mit einem
einheitlichen Verfahren und darüber bin
ich sehr froh wir sprechen von
unbürokratisch eine faire und gerechte
Verteilung von Flüchtlingen an diesem
Ziel ist die EU bisher immer gescheitert
klappt es diesmal
ich habe den Eindruck dass es diesmal
klappt es gibt eine Richtlinie die genau
für diesen Fall vorsieht dass es
unbürokratisch gemeinsam gleich für alle
Mitgliedstaaten erfolgt die
Flüchtlingsaufnahme und es könnte sein
dass wir sogar am Donnerstag bereits
diesen Beschluss dann fassen ja viel ist
ja heute von Zeiten wenn ihr die Rede
würden sie das auch in Bezug auf die
europäische Flüchtlingspolitik dann so
nennen ich würde es als sehr großen
Fortschritt benennen und ich hoffe aber
dass wir darüber hinaus auch an einem
gemeinsamen Asylsystem am Donnerstag und
Freitag im offiziellen Rat
weiterarbeiten können
auf wie viel Flüchtlinge stellt sich
denn Deutschland ein zahlen kann man
jetzt noch überhaupt nicht nennen es war
heute einheitlich der Bericht darüber
dass natürlich vor allen Dingen die
benachbarten Länder von der Ukraine im
Moment sehr viel Flüchtlingsaufnahme
haben viele vor allen Dingen darüber
über Familien über bekannte weniger in
geschaffenen Einrichtungen extra dafür
deswegen kann man zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
über Zahlen noch nicht sagen auch in
Deutschland sind ein paar hundert hier
angekommen aber das merken wir nicht
durch zusätzliche Unterkünfte wie gesagt
die gehen in Familien in bekannte und
insofern müssen wir da jetzt erstmal
abwarten aber auf alles vorbereitet sein
und ich bedanke mich zum einen für die
großartige Bereitschaft der Menschen
wenn man heute sieht 100.000 Menschen
die aus Solidarität mit der Ukraine auf
die Straße gegangen sind für Frieden ist
das ein tolles Signal und auch die
Bundesländer und Kommunen haben gesagt
dass sie aufnehmen wollen auch dafür bin
ich sehr dankbar lassen Sie mich nochmal
nachfragen unbürokratische Aufnahme was
heißt das denn ganz konkret es gibt
einen Verfahren nach Paragraph 24
Aufenthaltsgesetzes die Umsetzung einer
europäischen Richtlinie die europäische
Richtlinie wurde bisher noch nie gezogen
wir haben uns heute darauf geeinigt dass
die Kommission diesen Antrag stellen
soll und möglicherweise wird es dann am
Donnerstag schon beschlossen vielen Dank
Nancy fazer
ja bisher sollen schon über 300.000
Menschen aus der Ukraine geflohen sein
doch wie ist die Lage für die die nicht
das Land verlassen können oder wollen
Manuela Konrad und Svenja bergerhoff mit
Stimmen aus der Ukraine
ich heiße Juri wir befinden uns in
hakiff seit vier Tagen sind wir im
Bombenkeller im Schutzkeller und es geht
uns sehr schlecht hier werden nicht nur
militärobjekte beschossen sondern auch
zivile bauten die Wohnhäuser werden von
den Geschossen getroffen die Menschen
die überhaupt nichts mit den
Kampfhandlungen zu tun haben müssen sich
verstecken wir können das Haus nicht
verlassen den Keller nicht verlassen um
frische Luft zu schnappen es fehlt uns
an Wasser Lebensmittel es ist so gut wie
unmöglich zu den Einkaufszentren zu
gelangen
[Musik]
ich zeige Ihnen kurz wer mit mir
zusammen hier sitzt das sind alles
Einwohner unseres Hauses mit Hunden mit
Katzen und sogar eine Ausländerin ist
unter uns
die Bedingungen hier sind nicht gut
unser morgen startet mit dem Geräusch
von Explosionen unsere Tage vergehen mit
dem Geräusch von Schüssen die Abende mit
dem Geräusch von Sirenen und die Nächte
mit der Angst getroffen zu werden wir
sind hier im Schutzbunker um uns zu
verstecken und uns Überleben zu kämpfen
ich wünsche mir nur dass schnell alles
wieder normal wird und der ukrainischen
Armee viel Kraft
wir hoffen dass unsere Partner uns
helfen diesen Idioten diesen Feind Putin
zu stoppen damit wir in der Zukunft
friedlich und ruhig leben können
hier spricht ein drei aus Kiew wir haben
hier in meiner Stadt bis Montag eine
Ausgangssperre so habe ich Zeit etwas
über die Lage hier an der ukrainischen
Hauptstadt zu erzählen
insgesamt ist die Lage relativ ruhig
aber ich hatte eine schlaflose Nacht in
meiner Stadt kämpft nicht nur die Armee
sondern auch Zivilisten
die meisten Einwohner Kiew sind in
Schutzräumen oder in ihren Häusern wir
freuen uns auf den Moment in den alles
wieder in Frieden endet
ich bin mit meiner Familie zu Verwandten
gezogen sie wohnen genau wie wir im
Zentrum aber wir sind dort hingezogen
weil sie näher an der U-Bahn-Station
wohnen und von dort aus kann man schnell
runter Rennen um sich zu verstecken wenn
bombardiert wird
das haben wir in den ersten zwei Tagen
schon getan
wir haben circa fünf Stunden in der
Metro verbracht bevor wir wieder in
unsere Wohnungen zurückgegangen sind
wir wohnen im Erdgeschoss wenn wir
Sirenen oder Schüsse hören rennen wir in
den Hausflur dort sitzen wir an den
Wänden und warten bis es aufhört
it stops wir haben Lebensmittel und
Wasser gekauft für den Fall der Fälle
wir haben jetzt Ausgangssperre und
wurden informiert dass es schwere Kämpfe
rund um Kiew geben könnte deshalb
verlassen wir unser Zuhause gerade nicht
in Allround key so we are not leaving
wir sind hier in der Abteilung für
Suchtkranke und wir gehen nicht raus nur
wenn ein Mitarbeiter Brot holt wir haben
vier Leibe Brot für 30 Menschen bekommen
[Musik]
hier ist noch ein kleines Zimmer was wir
ausgestattet haben 30 Patienten sind
noch da ich bleibe bei Ihnen meine
Mitarbeiter habe ich zu ihren Familien
geschickt drei Tage halten wir durch das
Wasser reicht für Trinken und Kochen bei
der Menge von Menschen die hier gerade
sind
die Welt danach ist nicht mehr derselbe
wieder vor sagt heute Bundeskanzler
Scholz in einer Regierungserklärung in
der klar wurde dass auch die deutsche
Politik einen Kurswechsel vollzieht über
den historischen Einschnitt die Reden im
Bundestag Christiane hübscher auf der
Ehrentribüne begrüße ich den Botschafter
der Ukraine dr André Melnik
diese denkwürdige Sondersitzung des
Bundestags beginnt mit einem nicht enden
wollenden Applaus für Melnik er hatte
Deutschland regelrecht um Hilfe
angefleht in den letzten Tagen den
Bundeskanzler öffentlich kaltherzig und
stur genannt eine Minute und 12 Sekunden
lang erhebt sich das Parlament für ihn
stellvertretend für alle 40 Millionen
Ukraine nur die AFD bleibt sitzen
Olaf Scholz wird dann in seiner
Regierungserklärung versuchen eine
Begründung zu geben für einen
persönlichen und politischen umschwenk
wie es ihnen Nachkriegsdeutschland noch
nicht gegeben haben dürfte wir erleben
eine Zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die Welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die Welt
davor
im Kern geht es um die Frage ob macht
das Recht brechen darf ob wir es Putin
gestatten die Uhren zurückzudrehen in
die Zeit der Großmächte des 19
Jahrhunderts oder ob wir die Kraft
aufbringen kriegstabern wie Putin
Grenzen zu setzen
Scholz wirft dafür ein eisernes Mantra
über Bord die Bundesregierung wird der
Ukraine sofort Waffen zur Verteidigung
schicken und Deutschland wird mehr viel
mehr in die eigene Sicherheit
investieren etwas das die SPD bisher
immer verhindert hat aber machen wir uns
nichts vor bessere Ausrüstung modernes
Einsatzgerät mehr Personal das kostet
viel Geld
wir werden dafür
ein Sondervermögen Bundeswehr Einrichten
der Bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses
Sondervermögen einmalig mit 100
Milliarden Euro ausstatten die Mittel
werden wir für notwendige Investitionen
und Rüstungsvorhaben nutzen
wir werden von nun an Jahr für Jahr mehr
als zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes in unsere
Verteidigung investiert
für Oppositionsführer Merz ist die Lage
schwierig Scholz hat praktisch über
Nacht alles abgeräumt wofür die Union
Ihnen gerne kritisiert hätte der
Ausschluss Russlands von SWIFT
Waffenlieferungen wer Etat all das
unterstützen CDU und CSU und so bleibt
März nur der Hinweis auf die Belastung
der nächsten Generation
Sondervermögen ist nicht ein Vermögen
sondern ein Sondervermögen sind zunächst
einmal neue Schulden und wie wir diese
neuen Schulden aufnehmen und wie wir sie
dann möglicherweise in unserer
Verfassung verankern das geht nicht
allein mit einer Regierungserklärung am
Sonntagmorgen zu machen der FDP
Finanzminister kontert das sei der Preis
der Freiheit zahlbar sogar unter der
künftigen wiedereinhaltung der
Schuldenbremse Lindner erinnert daran
wer 16 Jahre lang das
Verteidigungsministerium führte
Friedrich Merz wir werden nicht danach
fragen
wer die Verantwortung für den Zustand
der Bundeswehr hat wir werden nicht mit
dem Finger aufeinander zeigen aber die
Investitionen in die Bundeswehr lieber
Friedrich Merz die sollten Sie nicht
führen mit der Warnung von neuen
Schulden das sind in Wahrheit natürlich
Kredite die wir aufnehmen in den
nächsten Jahren aber in dieser Weltlage
sind es zunächst und zumeist
Investitionen in unsere Freiheit auch
die Grünen hatten noch im Wahlprogramm
dass zwei Prozent Ziel der NATO
abgelehnt doch Putins Krieg so
Außenministerin baerbock sei ein
hinreichender Grund dafür
wenn man seine außenpolitische
180 Grad Wendung im richtigen Moment und
bei vollem Bewusstsein treffen muss
jetzt ist so traurig es ist der Moment
dafür
Vizekanzler Habeck spricht von einer
militärischen Vergewaltigung der Ukraine
durch Russland die die grüne
Friedenspartei zum Umdenken führen allen
Zweifeln zum Trotz hoch eine Position
des unbedingten Pazifismus die sich
sicherlich daraus dieser Geschichte
ableitet und sagt wir können nicht
weiter nächste Schuld auf uns Laden ich
achte es aber ich halte es für falsch
denn schuldig werden wir trotzdem wir
kommen mit sauberen Händen dann aus der
Sache nicht raus deswegen ist die
Korrektur die die Bundesregierung
gemacht hat also die Bereitschaft
schaffen zu liefern richtig die Linke
gesteht einen historischen Irrtum ein ja
der Aggressor heißt Putin doch die
Linksfraktion zieht andere Schlüsse
daraus meine Partei DIE LINKE räume ich
in aller Deutlichkeit ein dass wir die
Absichten der russischen Regierung
falsch eingeschätzt haben bei der Frage
was ist jetzt allerdings zu tun gilt
sind wir in mehreren und Punkten anderer
Auffassung und ich muss es einfach in
der Deutlichkeit sagen dieses hochrüsten
diese Militarisierung die können und
werden wir als LINKE nicht mittragen
auch die AFD verurteilt den russischen
Angriffskrieg sieht aber eine Mitschuld
bei der NATO und ist nicht einverstanden
mit höheren Militärausgaben
heute leider den Kalten Krieg
reaktiviert mit ihrer Rede das muss ich
so deutlich sagen
und wir müssen fragen welche sozialen
Folgen hat ihre Politik für die
deutschen Bürger diese müssen schon
jetzt überall mit steigenden Preisen
leben lernen Stichworte Benzinpreise
Heizkosten steigende Inflation wollen
sie allen Ernstes die Bundesregierung
sein die wieder Soldaten in einen Krieg
gegen Russland schickt das lehnen wir
ebenso ab wie die Lieferung von Waffen
in Kriegsgebiete es ist eine Zäsur in
der deutschen Politik es ist eine teure
Zäsur so viel ist schon klar und es ist
Putin der die ampelregierung zu diesem
dramatischen Kurswechsel zwingt
im Bundestag heute anwesend war der
ukrainische Botschafter in Deutschland
andere Melnik guten Abend guten Abend
Frau Pieper sie haben ja zuvor dringend
um Hilfe gebeten immer wieder an die
Bundesregierung appelliert was war denn
für sie das wichtigste heute
das war ein besonderer Tag nicht nur
jetzt für Deutschland sondern natürlich
auch für eine Video Ukraine für meine
Landsleute weil wir gesehen haben dass
dieser Kampf diese Kampf meine
Landsleute für ihre Staatlichkeit für
die Freiheit dass diese Kampf auch nicht
nur diese Empathie erfährt sondern auch
eine sehr sehr praktische Unterstützung
sowohl politisch als auch was die
Waffenlieferungen angeht und dafür sind
vor allem viele viele Ukraine heute an
diesem Tage sehr dankbar wie sehen Sie
denn die Lage Moment in der Ukraine wie
viel Hoffnung setzen Sie auf die
Friedensverhandlungen zwischen Russland
und der Ukraine
die Ukraine hat diesen Krieg nicht
begonnen aber wir sind bereit alles zu
tun der Miete damit er so schnell wie
möglich beendet wird dieses
Blutvergießen Seite 4 langen langen
Tagen das ist etwas Schreckliches ein
Inferno für uns alle auch für meine
Familie die genauso wie unser Präsident
selensky immer noch in Kiew bleibt und
ausharrt unter dem raketenbeschusse
deswegen die Chance für diplomatie ist
da und wir hoffen dass das keine
scheingespräche geben wird dass das
Putin nicht weiterhin spielte und
taktierte wenn das ein Angebot gibt dann
sind wir bereit sind unsere Regierung
bereit so schnell wie möglich zu
verhandeln um um diesen Horror zu
beenden
soll ja doch in Belarus stattfinden
obwohl von dort auch Raketen auf die
Ukraine abgefeuert wurden warum nun doch
das Einverständnis
soweit ich weiß ich kann ich kann das im
Moment ehrlich gesagt nicht bestätigen
dass das Weißrussland als diese Orte
schon
ausgewählt wurde in der Tat weil weil
eben wie sie sagen auch aus dem
belarussischem Boden wurde diese
Angriffe diese Krieg gestartet und es
gab immer wieder auch raketenschläge vom
Norden von unserem Nachbarstaat das hat
natürlich viele Menschen zu tief zu
tiefste erschüttert weil wir
schon nicht geglaubt haben dass wir
diese Situation haben deswegen ein
neutrale Ort wäre aus unserer Sicht viel
passende aber Hauptsache ist dass man
dass man vorankommte und dass man auf
einem diplomatischen Wege diesen
Wahnsinn stoppt
es gab ja heute auch eine große
Friedensdemo in Berlin wie wichtig sind
denn solche weltweiten Zeichen der
Verbundenheit
diese Solidarität die wir heute in
Berlin im Zentrum der Staat aber auch in
vielen vielen anderen deutschen Städten
Kommunen gesehen haben geben Mut uns
Ukraine diesen Kampf nicht aufzugeben
auf keinen Fall sondern weiterhin zu
kämpfen und zu zeigen der gesamten Welt
aber auch den Russen auch den Puten dass
das wir nicht und nie bereite sein
werden diesen Kriege kampfluss quasi zu
beenden sondern wir werden so lange da
sein und gerade stehen für die Heimat
für für unsere Familien solange das
notwendig ist und diese Zeichen dieser
Empathie die heute gerade heute
überwältigend war in ganz Deutschland
die sind wirklich Zeichen dessen dass
wir in diesen dramatischen Tagen und
Wochen die vielleicht uns immer noch für
uns liegen nicht allein gelassen werden
sagt der ukrainische Botschafter vielen
Dank nach Berlin
dankeschön das Gespräch haben wir direkt
vor der Sendung aufgezeichnet live bei
mir im Studio ist ja bei der
Politikwissenschaftler Karl Rudolf Korte
guten Abend ja guten Abend dann lassen
Sie uns doch da mal einordnen was da
heute im Bundestag passiert ist würden
sie auch von einer Zeitenwende sprechen
erstmal von einem großen Demokratie
Erlebnis angemessen als Reaktion auf
eine neue Realität ein realitätschock
hat die deutsche Politik erfahren und
heute ist praktisch die Antwort
formuliert worden auf einen zweiten
Kalten Krieg und zwar mit all dem was
eine Demokratie ausmacht eine Fülle an
unterschiedlichen Argumenten die
zusammengetragen worden sind Regierungen
Opposition alle kommen zu Wort und vor
allen Dingen man korrigiert sich dass
man früher Fehler gemacht hat das ist
genau die Provokation der Freiheit von
der Habeck heute auch sprach vor der
sich letztlich Putin fürchtet nicht vor
dem deutschen Parlament aber vor der
Idee der Freiheit was hat sie denn heute
am meisten überrascht ja die
Begrifflichkeiten die ausgewählt worden
sind fand ich beeindruckend also
freiheitsenergie beispielsweise was
Lindner formuliert hat oder auch die
militärische Vergewaltigung als
Begründung warum habe ich eigentlich als
grundsätzlicher Pazifist doch einer
Bewaffnung und einer Lieferung von
Waffen jetzt zustimmt das sind schon
wichtige Argumente und wichtige
Begrifflichkeiten gewesen und vor allen
Dingen das Politik paradox was wir
erleben dass ein Linker Kanzler mit fast
richtigen Kompetenz führt und zur
Aufrüstung geradezu antreibt dass es
vollkommen unerwartet und es macht die
ganze Koalitionsvereinbarung zur
Makulatur der Wappen in Kriegsgebiete
das war ja bisher ein No-Go warum diese
Kehrtwende ja weil die Realität eine
neue ist und insofern wir da seins
Vorsorge mit Zukunftssicherheit völlig
neu definieren
infrastrukturaufrüstung ist praktisch
das was Freiheit garantiert im
energiepolitischen im militärpolitischen
und das ist das neue Denken es gab ja
viel Applaus heute im Bundestag aber
auch Zwischenrufe als es um die
Aufrüstung der Bundeswehr ging wie
wichtig sehen Sie dieses Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr von 100 Milliarden Euro das
ist mehr als eine Symbolik es ist ein
Zeichen dass wir ja etwas verändern
müssen auch mit Geld Zukunftssicherheit
geht nur über Ressourcen Sicherheit die
wir über militärische Güter auf Bauch
wieder erreichen können wir müssen etwas
nachholen und das mit einem großen
Schlag also Bazooka hätte wahrscheinlich
normalerweise der ehemalige
Finanzminister Scholz dazu gesagt auf
Friedrich Merz hat heute vom
Kriegsverbrecher Putin gesprochen wie
sehen sie die Rolle der Opposition da
gerade sie war sehr konstruktiv heute
grundsätzlich die Opposition sie hat
gesagt wir arbeiten mit der Regierung
zusammen in dieser Notsituation um
praktisch auch auf die neue Realität
sich einzustellen dass wir insgesamt
eben sicherheits- und Außenpolitik neu
bewerten müssen und das nur zusammen
machen können also die je einiger wir
sind um je mehr wir Gewicht legen auf
eigene Verteidigung die wir bisher
vernachlässigt haben umso stärker kann
die Bundesrepublik sich schützen und das
ist auch eine Aufgabe an der die
Opposition sich beteiligt hat sich
Deutschland zu lange falscher Sicherheit
gewählt ja wir alle ganz offenbar wir
haben auch nie in Wahlkämpfen darüber
diskutiert außen Sicherheitspolitik war
ein exotisches Thema insofern müssen wir
selbst Umdenken wie wir uns selbst
zukünftig schützen können aber in einem
komplexen Thema es geht nicht nur um
Waffen es geht darum Energie vielen Dank
Professor Korte gerne
ja und während in Deutschland also der
Kurs der Politik grundländern geändert
wurde hat sich für die Menschen in der
Ukraine ihr ganzes Leben verändert es
herrscht Krieg Menschen fliehen sind
verzweifelt über den Kriegstag in der
Ukraine geldanhalt
wenn Bürger sich verabreden um gemeinsam
Benzinbomben herzustellen dann ist ein
neues Stadium des Schreckens erreicht
nutzt alles was ihr zur Hand habt um die
Angreifer zu stoppen diese Losung gab
die Armee aus und das schon bevor eine
weitere Nacht mit massiven Attacken auf
die Hauptstadt begann mit Leuchtspur
geschossen und Kanonen Donner bis dann
gegen ein Uhr der Feuerschein am
südwestlichen Nachthimmel die Explosion
des ölterminals von wasilkiff anzeigte
über 30 Kilometer vor Kiew
liebe Mitbürger sie alle sehen das Feuer
das kommt von unserem öldepot der Feind
will alles zerstören aber er wird nichts
erreichen den ganzen Tag lagen wir und
lag unser Flughafen unter Raketen
Beschuss und nun geht es weiter aber
alles wird gut auch wenn es nicht leicht
wird mit Gottes Hilfe werden wir das
durchstehen
nach dem ersten Schrecken meldete sich
bald der Katastrophenschutz und gab
Entwarnung
wir haben das Feuer innerhalb der Anlage
gehalten ist dehnt sich nicht aus und es
besteht keine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung
die Gefahr freilich bestand für die
Feuerwehrleute die sich dem Entfernung
entgegenstellten aber scheinbar wurde
niemand verletzt
gespenstische Ruhe dagegen in den
Straßen Kiews über das die Regierung
eine Ausgangssperre verhängt hat die
noch bis Montag in Kraft ist jeden der
draußen aufgegriffen wird betrachten wir
als feindlichen Agenten lautet die
Ansage und so verschanzten sich die
Bürger in ihren Wohnungen oder
verbrachten eine weitere Nacht begleitet
vom Geheul der Sirenen im
Luftschutzbunker oder in den Wartezonen
der U-Bahn von Freiwilligen mit dem
Nötigsten versorgt und verpflegt und
schöpften vielleicht ein wenig Kraft aus
der Gemeinschaft in die ihre Not sie
gezwungen hat
die Stimmung hier in Bombenkeller ist
gefasst es gibt viel menschliche Wärme
und wir helfen einander
alles scheint nun mehr oder weniger
unter Kontrolle wir sind auf einem guten
Weg unsere Soldaten haben die Sache in
der Hand
selbst das ukrainische Fernsehen hat
Studio und Redaktionsräume verlassen und
sendet die Nachrichten aus der
Tiefgarage weil es leider wieder
Fliegeralarm gibt müssen wir uns von
diesem Ort melden erklären die
Moderatoren aber viel hoffnungsvolles
haben sie nicht zu berichten die Kämpfe
gehen im ganzen Land weiter und als der
vierte Kriegstag über den Menschen
leeren Straßen erwachte und am fernen
Horizont die dunklen Rauchsäulen von den
Angriffen der Nacht erzählten meldete
sich der Bruder des Bürgermeisters mit
einem eindringlichen Hilferuf
ich bin Vladimir Klitschko und ich
appelliere an die ganze Welt diesen
Krieg den Russland angefangen hat zu
beenden
Zivilisten werden von Raketen getötet
oder von Spezialeinheiten ermordet und
das mitten in Europa wir sind auf dem
Weg in eine humanitäre Katastrophe sie
müssen die russische Aggression jetzt
mit allen Mitteln stoppen schon in einer
Stunde oder Morgen kann es zu spät sein
zögern Sie nicht und stoppen Sie die
russische Aggression
stoppen aber wie in den sozialen
Netzwerken kursieren dramatische
Aufnahmen von mutmaßlichen ukrainischen
Bürgern die russische Panzerkolonnen zum
Stillstand bringen wenigstens
vorübergehend und unter größter Gefahr
wo sie entstanden und ob sie echt sind
niemand kann das sagen immer wieder ist
auch von jungen russischen Gefangenen
und Deserteuren die Rede die angeblich
nichts vom Krieg wissen und denen
erzählt wurde sie zögen ins Manöver und
dann wieder Bilder einer
Überwachungskamera die russische
Soldaten beim Plündern eines
Ladengeschäfts zeigen sollen auch dies
ohne Nachweis und ohne Ortsangabe
Militär Kolonnen anscheinend russische
bewegen sich durch Wohnsiedlungen dieser
Aufnahmen sollen aus karkiff stammen in
dessen Zentrum sich die Russen Berichten
zu folge heute Straßenkämpfe mit den
Verteidigern lieferten
ob diese Aufnahmen dann das Ergebnis
dieser Konfrontationen zeigen ist
wiederum kaum verlässlich zu ermitteln
Falke sei aber wieder vollständig unter
ukrainischer Kontrolle ließ schließlich
der Gouverneur der Region verlauten
jedoch gelang es den Angreifern offenbar
in der Nacht eine Gaspipeline in der
Nähe in die Luft zu jagen und während es
weiterhin jede Verantwortung für zivile
Opfer und Schäden zurückweist meldet
sich Moskau mit einer weiteren
erfolgreichen Zwischenbilanz
insgesamt haben wir jetzt 975 Objekte
der militärischen Infrastruktur der
Ukraine getroffen darunter 23
befehlszentren und 48 Radarstationen 31
Luftabwehrstellungen hinzukommen acht
abgeschossene Flugzeuge sieben
Hubschrauber 223 Panzer und
143 LKW
diese Zahlen sind ebenso wenig zu
überprüfen wie die twitter-bilder der
ukrainischen Milizen die ihrem Gegner
deftige Flüche und üble Verwünschungen
entgegenschleudern oder das Video des
ukrainischen Militärs das den Drohnen
Angriff auf einen russischen Konvoi
zeigen soll Russland verlor so Kiew
bereits 146 Panzer 27 Flugzeuge und 26
Hubschrauber sowie
4.300 Soldaten
Präsident selenski nachdem er dem Westen
und auch Deutschland für die
militärische Hilfe dankte Verurteilte in
seiner jüngsten Ansprache die Angreifer
als Kriegsverbrecher
ihre Beteuerungen keine zivilen Ziele
anzugreifen sind Lügen
von der ersten Stunde an haben sie
bewusst auch Zivilisten und alle
Einrichtungen unseres Alltags ins Visier
genommen
Kraftwerke Krankenhäuser Kindergärten
und Wohnungen all das wird jeden Tag
und während auf allen offiziellen und
inoffiziellen Kanälen die
Anschuldigungen und Appelle Lügen
Propaganda Hilferufe und Beleidigungen
hin und her fliegen rüstet sich die
ukrainische Hauptstadt für die nächste
kriegsnacht und vielleicht für den
nächsten russischen raketenregen
ja und die Zahl derer die aus der
Ukraine fliehen reist nicht ab wie schon
gesagt über 300.000 sollen ist
inzwischen sein und die kommen auch in
Polen an und werden erst einmal versorgt
über die Situation an der Grenze
berichtet Natalie Steger
es ist ein Grenzübergang an der Autobahn
aber die Menschen drängen in der Nacht
zu Fuß aus der Ukraine nach Polen raus
wie auch immer endlich ist die
beschwerliche Reise aus dem Kriegsgebiet
geschafft viele Frauen mit Kindern
harren auf der Autobahn aus
and the went wir kamen zu Fuß und es war
sehr hart
aber jetzt sind wir hier und es ist okay
viel besser als in der Ukraine
auf der polnischen Seite wird die
Autobahn zum Parkplatz Angehörige suchen
geflohene Freiwillige die Transport
anbieten wollen die Menschen aufnehmen
aber es gibt kein vor und kein zurück
damit die geflohenen nicht so lange in
der Kälte warten müssen werden sie in
Bussen zu einem Einkaufszentrum gebracht
als Zwischenstation bevor es weitergeht
es sind kaum Männer darunter weil die
Männer zwischen 18 und 60 Jahren in der
Ukraine bleiben müssen und das Land
verteidigen sollen
sie war nur hat es noch mit seiner
Familie geschafft aber wird sie wohl
alleine weiterreisen lassen euer Tag ich
werde wohl zurückgehen ja in die Ukraine
weil da meine Freunde sind und es gibt
die Notwendigkeit mein Land zu sichern
aber
sie haben sogar einen Autokindersitz
mitgebracht Agnieszka und Dominica
bieten Fahrten nach Krakau oder Katowice
an und alles was auf dem Weg liegt es
gibt unzählige solcher Helfer und
Helferinnen
das ist doch normal dass die Leute
helfen und das ist alles das ist keine
große Geschichte wir werden einfach
gebraucht und wir müssen es machen
Grenzübergang mit der K wo die Menschen
seit Anfang der russischen Offensive
nach Polen kommen oft seit zwei drei
Tagen unterwegs ausgehungert erschöpft
Essen Sachspenden viele Polinnen und
Polen helfen auch hier
hier zieht schlechtes Wetter auf aber
die Menschen die es nach Polen geschafft
haben die werden jetzt in Busse gebracht
oder Privatleute holen sie ab und ihre
Reise hat ein vorläufiges Ende und sie
sind in Sicherheit aber auf der
ukrainischen Seite da müssen die
Menschen stundenlang warten bis er es
hierüber nach Polen schaffen
Tag 4 die Organisation klappt Polen
kümmert sich vorbildlich um die
Flüchtlinge es ist eine beklemmende
Routine eingekehrt
eine weitere Anlaufstelle für Migranten
ist die Slowakei Ritter Hilpert
beobachtet für uns die Situation ganz im
Osten des Landes direkt an der
ukrainischen Grenze rund 250 km entfernt
von Lemberg
Britta wie versucht man denn den
Menschen dort zu helfen
na hier zum Beispiel ganz konkret hier
an diesem Tisch bekommen Ukrainer die
hier gerade angekommen sind eines
slowakische SIM-Karte damit Sie mit
Ihren Lieben in der Ukraine Kontakt
halten können damit Sie aber auch
organisieren können dass sie hier in das
Slowakei oder von Ukrainern die etwas
weiter weg wollen zum Beispiel in
Tschechien oder auch in Deutschland
abgeholt werden das passiert hier sehr
häufig diese Karten bekommen die Ukraine
hier umsonst aber natürlich gibt es auch
noch andere Hilfe da wenn man darüber
gehen dann sehen wir ein Zelt von vielen
von NGOs von Hilfsorganisationen in
diesem Fall die Malteser das Rote Kreuz
ist hier und ganz viele Privatleute die
sich auf den Weg gemacht haben die dann
hier Transport umsonst anbieten oder
einfach nur heiße Getränke und bisschen
was warmes zu essen was bei jetzt drei
Grad tatsächlich auch wirklich notwendig
ist denn immer noch kommt man da drüben
von der ukrainischen Seite von der Stadt
uschkarot schubweise vor allem Frauen
und Kinder mit kleinen Kindern hier
rüber mit riesigen Koff die sehr häufig
hoffen dass Sie hier nur ein paar Tage
ausharren müssen und sehr häufig auch
abgeholt werden von Freunden und von
Verwandten aber es kommen eben auch
immer mehr Leute an die eigentlich gar
nicht wissen wohin die Werke laufen sind
vor den ersten Schrecken des Krieges in
Kiew oder in krakev ja sie sagen das
kommen immer neue an gibt es denn
genügend Kapazitäten für die Flüchtlinge
dort
das ist die große und die entscheidende
Frage da hängt es natürlich auch sehr
davon ab wie lange das Kriegsgeschehen
jetzt noch dauert wie intensiv das wird
ich habe den Eindruck dass auf der
anderen Seite ich habe da Bilder Webcam
Bilder gesehen immer noch sehr sehr
viele Menschen warten natalie hat es ja
in ihrem Stück auch dargestellt es
müssen Kilometer lange Staus sein
hunderte tausende von Menschen die
ausreisen wollen die einfach in
Sicherheit wollen ich will aber auch
noch mal erwähnen dass ich hier
tatsächlich auch ein paar Leute
getroffen habe ein paar Männer die in
die andere Richtung fahren in die
Ukraine die sagen jetzt ist der Moment
wo wir wieder nach Hause fahren müssen
wir haben hier einen guten Job in der EU
aber wir müssen nach Hause fahren und
wir müssen unser Land verteidigen ich
glaube direkt hinter mir kommt gerade
ein solcher Wagen aus der Ukraine der
darüber fährt aber diesen Menschen muss
ich sagen kann man nur viel Glück
wünschen bei diesem Vorhaben
vielen Dank Britta Hilpert für diese
Eindrücke von der Grenze
angemeldet waren 20.000 Menschen es kam
weit über 100.000 die heute in Berlin
gegen den russischen Einmarsch in die
Ukraine und für den Frieden
demonstrierten zwischen Brandenburger
Tor und Siegessäule versammelten sich so
viele Demonstranten in und Demonstranten
wie lange nicht mehr das Motto stoppt
den Krieg Frieden für die Ukraine und
ganz Europa ein Bündnis aus
Gewerkschaften Kirchen Friedensgruppen
mit Umweltschutzorganisationen hatte zu
dem Protest aufgerufen viele Plakate
machen den russischen Präsidenten Putin
persönlich verantwortlich für den Krieg
seit vier Tagen zeigen Menschen rund um
den Globus ihr Mitgefühl und ihre
Solidarität mit dem bedrängten
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern
ja für uns auf der Demo ist Stefanie
gagosch was ist denn im Moment noch los
in Berlin
ja Antje es war heute irgendwie eine
wirklich bewegender Moment die
Demonstrationen wie Kundgebungen sind
vorbei aber ich habe in meinem Leben
noch nie so viele in meinem Reporter
Leben noch nie so viele Menschen auf der
Straße gesehen die sich solidarisch
zeigen wollten angekündigt waren 20.000
der Veranstalter spricht von 500.000 es
war ein unglaublich viele wir haben die
ganze Zeit auf der Demo dreht und auch
auf der Kundgebung haben mit Menschen
geredet die sehr besorgt waren auch
davor dass das ganze vielleicht
eskalieren kann die sagen wir müssen ein
Zeichen setzen die ukrainische Gemeinde
ist schon seit dem Beginn des Konfliktes
jeden Tag vor der russischen Botschaft
jetzt auch das kann man hinter mir sehen
sie fordern Frieden in der Ukraine
natürlich singen die Nationalhymne und
eine Ukrainerin die inzwischen in
Deutschland lebt auch schon seit
längerer Zeit war heute auf der
Kundgebung dabei und hat auch gesprochen
sie ist jetzt bei mir
Komplex Alexandra binärd und sie haben
auch Familie in der Ukraine ja ich habe
Familien die Ukraine meine Mutter lebt
in Kiew und es ist zur Seite sieht es so
aus dass ich sie nicht rausholen kann
weil es einfach zu gefährlich ist was
ist denn das für ein Gefühl also ich
habe auch mit den Menschen heute die
haben ja auch immer wieder Fotos gezeigt
auch ganz schreckliche Bilder man kriegt
das ja immer mit man schreibt jeden Tag
wie wie geht es einem damit
ja wir sind in Ohnmacht wir sind wütend
es ist ehrlich gesagt ein schreckliches
Gefühl weil die jeden Morgen wacht man
auf und guckt dass man Nachrichten bzw
als erstes schreibt man der Mutter und
dann der Vater ist alles okay bei euch
und dann kommt zurück ja ich musste
jetzt in den Luftschutzkeller oder ja
alles okay und es ist es ist Krieg es
ist Krieg und dieser Krieg geht uns alle
an der Krieg ist in Europa
das habe ich zwar heute auch meine
Erfahrung auf der Kundgebung und dann
darf der Demonstration die Leute haben
große große Angst davor dass es skaliert
wie war das für sie heute zu sehen die
große Solidarität doch in Deutschland es
war sehr wichtig zu sehen dass heute
eine halbe Million tatsächlich mit uns
am Brandenburger Tor also zwischen der
Siegessäule und Brandenburger Tor
zusammen gestanden haben aber ich muss
sagen der Krieg der Krieg läuft es ist
schon eskaliert es werden es sterben
jeden Tag Menschen und zivile Menschen
und es kann es kann nicht sein dass wir
hier irgendwie über mögliche Sanktionen
das oder noch etwas reden jede Minute
kostet ukrainische Leben und wir müssen
handeln
was von fordern Sie jetzt weiter von
Deutschland also Deutschland hat sich ja
doch auch ganz schön weit schon bewegt
heute ja das ist gut wir fordern
weiterhin Waffenlieferungen weil wir
verteidigen dort unseren Frieden und
unsere Freiheit und es wird auch nicht
anders gehen als die zu verteidigen wir
fordern embargo an komplettes embargor
an Rohstoffen aber die aus Russland
kommen wir müssen Russland um zwingen
wir müssen mit Russland wir dürfen mit
Russland keine Geschäfte mehr machen und
wir fordern ein endgültigen Stopp von
Nord und Nord Stream 2
und sie selbst mit welchem Gefühl gehen
Sie jetzt durch die nächsten Tage
ich hoffe dass es bald vorbei ist aber
ich weiß es nicht es ist ich hoffe jeden
Tag dass gute Nachrichten kommen und ich
hoffe sehr dass mein Land im Frieden und
im Wohlstand leben kann und ich denke in
Deutschland trägt da moralische ethische
und historische Verantwortung alles
Mögliche dafür zu tun was kann denn der
einzelne vielleicht auch tun haben sie
da eine Idee also wenn man jetzt sagt
okay die Politik muss da handeln aber
was ist vielleicht auch für den
Einzelnen möglich zu tun ja sie wissen
jetzt kommen ganz viele geflüchtete zu
uns aus der Ukraine es sind ja mein
Vater hat mir heute erzählt die Schlange
an der polnischen ukrainischen Grenze
ist 40 Kilometer lang 40 km lang
wir nehmen Sie natürlich auf und
es wird humanitäre Hilfe für sie
gebraucht spenden sie Geld dafür die
humanitäre Hilfe kümmern sie um sich um
die geflüchteten wenn Sie ein Auto
erfahren Sie dann mit dem Auto zu Grenze
und holen Menschen ab ich danke Ihnen
sehr alles Gute für ihre Familie die
Veranstalter haben übrigens weitere
Demonstrationen und Kundgebungen
angekündigt heute vielen Dank Stefanie
gargosch
er kümmern sie sich um die geflüchteten
hat sie gerade gesagt erste Flüchtlinge
aus der Ukraine sind schon in
Deutschland in Freiburg haben mehr als
150 Kinder in Bussen an eine
lebensgefährliche Flucht liegt hinter
ihnen Dorothea Dörner berichtet
über 70 Stunden Fahrt liegt hinter ihnen
159 Heimkinder mit ihren Betreuern aus
der Ukraine sind am Vormittag in
Freiburg im Breisgau angekommen die
Kinder zwischen einem und 17 Jahren sind
müde und hungrig auch mit dabei Roman
comico der Heimleiter aus
kiewic Nico şu deată vătunler wir haben
die Kinder gebeten werdet werde trinken
noch essen um nicht das Bedürfnis haben
auf die Toilette zu gehen alle haben
Hunger in den letzten drei Tagen gab es
nur zwei Mahlzeiten die Kinder kommen
aus einem Heim in der Nähe von Kiew mit
vier Bussen flüchteten sie über Polen
nach Deutschland über 2.000 km die lange
Fahrt nicht ohne dramatische
Zwischenfälle
in einer Stadt Romano das ist weiter
weiter westlich Wurm wurme gedacht
hatten die sind jetzt außer gefahren
sind sie von Drohnen also beschossen
worden ist die Kinder sind sehr
erschrocken ukrainische Polizisten die
die Busse begleitet haben hätten die
Kinder beschützt erzählt Roman cormico
verletzt wurde dabei niemand der
Freiburger Oberbürgermeister Martin
Hornis geschockt von den Erzählungen
also 10 Stunden an der ukrainischen
Grenze eine mobil machen wo ein Vater
aussteigen muss sein eigenes Kind im Bus
zurücklassen muss also das kann man sich
eigentlich westeuropäisch kann ich
vorstellen denn Männer im Alter zwischen
18 und 60 Jahren dürfen zurzeit yoka
ihnen nicht verlassen die Busfahrer
hatten Glück und durften weiterfahren
mit der ersten Gruppe mit den ich
persönlich gesprochen habe waren
dreijähriges Kind das war komplett
eingenässt und hatte nur ein Handtuch
umgebunden weil sie kein Ersatzkleidung
mehr hatten im Bus die ganzen
Materialien der ganze Kleider kommt der
sozusagen mit den ukrainischen Bussen
nachgefahren weil wir in Dresden im
buswechsel organisiert haben in der
Turnhalle eines Gymnasiums gibt es Essen
und die Kinder werden medizinisch
untersucht was in ihren Köpfen vorgeht
das kann im Moment niemand sagen
wir sind dann also
in wenigen Stunden nach dem Kriegsbeginn
sind die Kinder um zehn Stunden zehn
Jahre alt
diese Kinder sind in Sicherheit sie
werden erstmal in
flüchtlingsunterkünften und in einer
Jugendherberge untergebracht
[Musik]
wenn sie den Menschen in der Ukraine
helfen wollen können Sie das tun beim
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine iban.de
65-100 400 600-100 400 600 hallo infos
auch unter Spenden zdf.de oder im ZDF
Text auf Seite 890
und zum Schluss ist live in der Ukraine
für uns noch mal Katrin Eigendorf ca 200
km südlich von Kiew wie ist bei ihnen
die Lager
die Lage ist hier sehr angespannt das
ist auch der Grund warum wir jetzt hier
aus der Halle unseres Hotels senden
müssen es gibt viele freiwilligengruppen
die hier in der Stadt patroullieren die
sich praktisch als eine Art
volksmedizier betätigen und die wirklich
sehr nervös sind und Angst haben dass
hier russische undercover Agenten
unterwegs sind und die haben uns im
Prinzip gesagt wir dürften jetzt hier
draußen nicht mehr drehen also auf der
einen Seite wirklich große
Kampfbereitschaft der russischen
Bevölkerung aber eben auch zunehmende
Nervosität die auch dazu führt dass wir
Journalisten jetzt sicherlich damit
rechnen können das höre ich auch von
anderen Kollegen dass wir hier nur noch
eingeschränkt arbeiten können denn die
Nerven liegen jetzt hier am dritten Tag
des am vierten Tag des Krieges auch
ziemlich blank und die Leute eben sehen
sich sehr unter Druck haben einfach
Angst um ihre Sicherheit das führt dann
zu solchen Situationen wir müssen jetzt
mal gucken wie wir hier weiter berichten
wie vielleicht im Moment haben wir uns
hier erstmal in die Halle unseres Hotels
zurückgezogen und versuchen von hier aus
weiter zu berichten ja was hören sie für
den von dort aus über die Situation in
der Hauptstadt in Kiew
die Situation in der Hauptstadt in Kiew
ist ziemlich dramatisch die Menschen
richten sich dort wirklich darauf ein
dass sie eine längere Belagerung
ertragen können wir haben mit einigen
Menschen geredet ich habe zum Beispiel
gesprochen mit einer jungen Mutter die
im zweiten Monat schwanger ist zwei
Kinder hat und dort in Kiew feststeckt
und sagt ich kann im Prinzip die Stadt
nicht verlassen ich will als Schwangere
mich jetzt nie hier nicht auf einen
ungewissen Weg machen die haben ihre
komplette Wohnung verbarrikadiert sie
sagt wir wissen nicht ob ihr welche
dauerhaft einfach noch Strom und Wasser
haben wir richten uns im Prinzip auf
eine lange Belagerung dieser Stadt mit
ungewissem Ausgang ein also die Menschen
sind schon auf der einen Seite sehr
verzweifelt aber auch eben sehr
entschlossen hier für ihr Land
einzutreten aber die Situation wird eben
mit jedem Tag den dieser Krieg andauert
doch für die Menschen belastender und
dramatischer vielen Dank für diesen
Bericht aus der Ukraine Kathrin
Eigendorf
ja das war es an dieser Stelle erstmal
vom ZDF Spezial wir melden uns gleich
wieder nach den 19 Uhr heute Nachrichten
bis gleich
[Musik]
Berlin direkt mit Theo Paul
die russische Invasion in der Ukraine
was Deutschland aus seiner gescheiterten
Politik lernen muss
Berlin direkt heute Abend im ZDF
[Musik]